(shimmering orchestral music)
- [Narrator] Ladakh, India
is home to one of the
highest optical telescopes in the world.
Its environment makes
it ideal for stargazing.
(shimmering orchestral music)
(light piano music)
- [Narrator] The Indian
Astronomical Observatory
is spread across 120 acres of land,
and located at the northern tip of India.
(light piano music)
- [Narrator] The
remoteness of its location
makes it ideal for astronomical study.
(light orchestral music)
(quiet rustling)
(light piano music)
- [Narrator] The observatory's
altitude of approximately
two and a half miles above sea level
allows the scientists to
collect a wider range data
than they would at lower levels.
But the isolated location
means that often,
the only other people the scientists and
engineers see are the occasional tourists.
(slow, dramatic music)
(light orchestral music)
- [Narrator] Whether you're
looking up as an astronomer,
or just a traveler, there's
no night sky quite like this.
(soft beep)